would you say that um like obviously
you said Benny was a big inspiration but
like just the you know I feel like you
and you and Griselda have similar
business models in terms of yo when we
drop we're gonna have the merch we're
gonna have the vinyl we're gonna make
sure that fans can show up and support
us with where it counts like you might
not pay for the project but hey we gotta
we got a hoodie we got a t we would you
say that like with what Griselda kind of
did I don't know who was doing that
first but no on the on the merch side in
that whole thing that was definitely
Griselda they they CA they helped
introduce the whole formula to how to
actually capitalize shout out to gun
because guns no shut up the gun like and
that's another thing like you know if
gun
ain't really do what he did you know I
wouldn't had a motivation to really take
it serious as well I had to really see
that it was money to be made and really
see how to really connect with the
people and gun figure that out you know
I'm saying fathers like how to actually
capitalize on the fan base and [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying so so so shout out
to the Hulk Rosetta so yeah yeah that
that that that that that whole formula
is is that whole independent formula
started you know with them over there
yeah you know I mean fire is that way of
course of course like definitely
definitely 100
um